yeah i donated plasma for money two
times a week for four years in college
damn damn sometimes is that that
gambling addiction again right
that's just being poor in college i
guess damn why don't you donate semen
like a [ __ ]
human being i i got all nervous and they
shut me down i didn't have enough in the
cup
tried it
[Laughter]
damn you know we call that shallow
cupping dude
there's nothing lamborghini some guy
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do damn they said you know what we're
good
we're awesome so they didn't pay you uh
no no
hey how much is it to give your semen uh
how much do you get from
it was a lot like it was way more than
plasma like you got 60 bucks a week but
for like
four hours of time giving plasma for
semen it was like a couple hundred
dollars
you couldn't figure out any other way to
make money nick
i i had a job i worked full time all
during college
and you needed how much money did you
need you're making like ten dollars an
hour i'm paying
rent yeah
not everybody is an athlete that gets
everything taken care of for them okay
some of the people in this room didn't
even finish high school because of
certain issues they had going on in
their life
what i'm saying is nick obviously was
working at the bookstore
he was he was about to quit college to
gamble
okay nick what would you do with your
money in college
uh pay rent food groceries
and they'll try to go home once in a
while
yeah i mean it was half my plasma there
was actually a guy at the plasma clinic
because they would you get a little
receipt and it had a number and you go
up to an atm
and there was a guy who just sat there
and sold weed to the atm
and uh yeah that's that was that's where
your money went
but that was just the extra and it was a
nice gig because you could sit there on
your laptop watch a movie do some
homework how much
how long do they take it out if you
think about a half hour an hour four i
could do it in 40 if you pump real hard
oh oh right it would go in cycles you'd
go like 10 minutes on
then 10 minutes relax and they put
saline back in then 10 minutes on
and then and then oh man
it's all coming back to me because there
were cycles and after it would stop and
you had to get to this one line
and like on the third cycle if you were
just short you had to wait like a whole
another 25 minutes
another cycle so that last one you're
like are you doing how many times a week
two times
you could only go two times a week and
there was like there's a payment cut off
for 175 pounds
the second time of the week you got
instead of your second time you get 25
but if you're over 175 pounds you get
35. so i'd wear my winter coat and like
extra clothes because i was right on the
border of 175 pounds
wow right
you're pushing the limits to get that
extra you can't donate blood if you've
got tattoos you know that
uh and like recently if you got them
like within a year you can't donate
blood
oh you have to wait a while yeah i can't
donate blood because they're using
because using steroids yeah
really they have to use the intravenous
drugs ever
or intra intramuscular too i think so
yeah it must have because i told them
this
we can't take your blood i said damn all
right
yeah and i already had it out of me
she went to that jackoff clinic i'm not
doing that i have a buddy who got a note
in the mail the other day and said he
has like 11 children out there that's
too crazy to me so that's what they do
with the semen oh yeah give it out you
seen that vince vaughn movie
where it was like delivery kids delivery
man
well one of the true story too here's a
thing you don't know that goes on a lot
of these women who are in beauty
pageants
beauty women like miss america yeah miss
america miss whatever man
yeah miss haystack miss frickin uh
miss ventura miss napalm or whatever i
don't know what it's like in some
countries but
you uh they they um
those women will donate their eggs
that's how a lot of those women make
money
you're wondering how a lot of these hot
girls make money and how they're
surviving
and you know like what is this like bang
energy isn't paying all these women you
know
that skinny tea can't pay everybody
totally and it can't so how they're
doing it is they're making big money
selling their eggs because then a lot of
men will just be like well i already
have every
i like what i have in my life i ha you
know i like how i think i i just need
more attractiveness
so then they go to those egg farmers and
they say hey let me get an egg out of
you know
miss uh south dakota you know 48 or 71
or whatever i feel like that's a hard
road some
but some of them instagram thoughts also
just selling their body
well someone were selling body yeah but
some of them were selling eggs
selling sex selling oh someone said
something but some of them selling uh
eggs is much more lucrative though you
can get 30 000 for a batch of eggs if
you're smart as well
you were considered that cat uh i looked
into it for a short amount of time in
college
i will know it be honest now let's all
get honest here
there we go now college is what's after
i want to [ __ ] i don't want to shock
chappelle
new realms chef's like here's a picture
of me in college dude
and it's him and it is born
[Laughter]
baby he's like i was eight pounds 11
ounces
ufc louisville
it was hot as hell i'm like that's an
incubator
but so you looked into so you've heard
of this this is a thing that women think
about
yeah me and a bunch of my friends were
trying to figure out how to make money
in college because we're all broke
um there was a girl who ended up selling
pictures of her feet
and then another girl said oh can we
sell our eggs the same way guys can
sell their sperm and so we tried to look
into it and what ended up happening is
like
it's weird because the process is so
invasive but you could get a lot of
money for a couple eggs
you guys decide not to do it though yeah
no
the feet picture seemed like a better
deal you sold your
feet picks i did sell pictures of
somebody else's feet for a short amount
of time
amen and shout out jason tebow who i've
used his penis picture before
girls do that a lot with nudes too
they'll send
uh their friends nudes to a guy because
they're like oh like
i'm on my period right now i'm bloated
or something can i use your nudes and
send it to him
and we'll do that that's cool wow you
know what that's called it's called
teamwork
teamwork it makes the dream work wow it
makes something work
can you look up the uh call how much an
egg is for a woman
because here's now you want to talk
about disparity in the wage gap
i'm going to show you right here from
the beginning
whoa look at this look at the cost on
this what is it
twelve thousand dollars well we made ten
thousand
twelve you guys make sperm ten thousand
dollars
previously donated has paid twelve
thousand yeah if he's approved if you're
like a grade a donor
so it says egg donors are paid for every
donation have the potential to earn at
least seventy thousand dollars
after completing multiple egg donation
cycles
wow the first time egg donors paid 10
grand
i jack off in a cup i get 300 bucks
that's what i'm saying
if you have enough yeah if you have
enough you show up a milliliter shy
dude nothing's spilling over and you're
back at the bookstore somebody clean it
up
back at the bookstore trying to get her
paid to get a parlay to pay for rent
yeah yeah look how vague it is dude men
are paid
anywhere from 35 to 125
show a little pride bud 35 to jack
and you got to hit the cup man you know
what yeah you gotta hit the cup they
should give you an extra ten dollars for
getting it in the cup
mm-hmm i had a buddy that paid four
hundred dollars to jerk himself off
himself he went to school
[Laughter]
she's a happy ending
y'all too green behind the ears yeah she
snatched my money out of my hand and
also
some dude knocked on the door he said
time's up and i was like
then i had to wait for my buddy because
he was still in there and they were like
your friend's going to be a little bit
longer
and so he comes out i was like what'd
you do he goes oh i just
paid 400 just to jerk himself
you know why i looked at her i was like
what yeah
yeah oh we did dude you could do that
what a waste of [ __ ] somebody because
i was going to college
i was and it was like
i was just going to college he was like
yo let's do something you know like it's
your last night
in town it's good so i can jack off we
didn't know it was a whorehouse it
looked like a strip
no that wasn't in louisville that was
back home in arizona
well also one thing yeah when i lived in
tucson man it was easy to get down to
mexico and get into trouble you could
buzz right down there and
jerk off over there for you know thirty
dollars
they got them donkey shows in mexico now
yes
but a lot of the donkeys are uh i've
retired at some of the greats
yeah they go those long stretches
oh yeah long stretches
yeah dude how long does a donkey last oh
they got years bro
yeah pumping they got a little uh they
got this little seabiscuit junior down
there that i've seen before
junior sorry
it sounds like it sounds like a nice
time don't it yeah tacos
see a donkey show then when you actually
see how the sausage is made it'll break
your heart man
damn yeah man you gotta go down there
and see the little seabiscuit junior
you think nick's [ __ ] giving us a sad
story about jacking off and donating
blood in college yeah
somebody's mexican women the things they
gotta do just to [ __ ] sleep at night
man nick so confused he's jacking off at
the blood
gonna tell me he doesn't have enough
just so we can
quit school and bet on barley
thank god i should have read this guy's
resume i know that
um he's a hard worker though i'll keep
going man
i gotta keep going
is